falleció una mañana de verano tenía 84
años hablamos de issey miyaki uno de los
diseñadores más excepcionales del siglo
XX en japonés y seis significa la vida
miyake tres casas
el cuerpo la moda el mundo
[Música]
pensaba que los cuerpos debían ser
libres que era posible crear ropa a
partir de cualquier material sin límite
pero sin desperdicio que nunca había que
perder su identidad sino trascenderla en
vez de insertar prefería dejar brillar a
su equipo era gracioso generoso no pudo
venir a París para presentar su
colección moda masculina verano 2023
[Música]
quien es uno de mis diseñadores
preferidos cuando hace algo es arte
un salón tal como San Lorenzo u otros
a veces también es arte aplicado pero No
necesariamente es peyorativo
[Música]
Y pues también es la moda que va y viene
que no dura y al mismo tiempo permanece
son muchas contradicciones
entonces aquí es posible leer muchas
cosas a través de un desfile que es más
que eso
encontraron algo muy fuerte y muy
original
[Música]
así sigan existiendo diseñadores
estrella que aún crean ser dioses
todopoderosos la nueva tendencia tal
como lo hacen es jugarse la
colectivamente el grupo la comunidad la
familia son sacados a la luz
lucalium dingui vive y trabaja en Cape
Town en África del sur pero su ámbito de
investigaciones mucho más básico
nuestro punto de vista es sabernos
apoyado en el artesanado y los seres
humanos que le dan vida
entonces colaboramos con la comunidad
caves en burkina faso queríamos
desarrollar eso para saber cómo
funcionan las empresas emergentes como
creación e impacto social solo pueden
ser uno solo
estamos orgullosos porque ante todo esta
concepción del tejido nos acercó y es
así como concedimos las cosas
tuvimos la oportunidad de visitarlos y
entender la fuente de su trabajo Fue
inspirador contar con la presencia de
esas personas que tienen tanta fineza y
sinceridad
y la forma en que conciben el tejido ha
hecho progresar el ADN de nuestra marca
en París para su colección verano 2023
Celeste durry diseñadora de la joven
Márquez trabajó con nada menos que tres
artistas
funcionar en sinergia con otros artistas
y ellos se dan naturalmente y es cierto
que acompaño a imani en su gira de su
nuevo álbum Y entonces mientras hacía
esta colección estaba sumergida en sus
piezas h24 y ella en mi ropa y
recíprocamente esa es la historia tejer
pasarelas entre las distintas
disciplinas la música La pintura la
danza
Está también Gael Fede que no son rocos
su aparición furtiva cuando no es modelo
pero tuvo la gentileza de venir a
desfilar y a unirse a nosotros somos una
familia y queremos darle el gusto a la
gente
cuando prepara su imagen cómo le dan
ganas de vestirnos
mostrarse
depende de los años de los proyectos en
cualquier caso sobre el proyecto
vudúcelo una verdadera investigación
sobre el vudú el color fue muy
importante que los colores en el vudú
quieran decir algo uno no se viste de
cualquier forma con cualquier color
entonces tuvimos mucho rojo el rojo es
el color femenino color del femenino
sagrado de La potencia de la sangre de
la vida trato de que mi vida sea
coherente con lo que defiendo
ahora entonces cómo traduce todo esto en
la ropa en la colección Empiezo con los
textiles el material las telas me
apasionan los estampados los motivos y
las texturas de las materias yo trabajo
artesanal todo ese trabajo de
manufacturas textiles
porque no lo parece Pero en realidad es
complicado estos son los lienzos de
Julián hay muchos colores cuando se hace
con ellos yakuax es muy complicado no se
pueden aplicar los mismos colores porque
es como la aguada usted mezcla elige
colores de hilos pero cuando los teje
juntos del resultado es distinto
de hecho los colores se mezclan y no
tiene nada que ver
lo que quiero es hablarle a la gente de
hoy a todas las categorías de edad
hombres y mujeres la colección es unisex
la idea es aportar color belleza en todo
caso de su espero Pero de cualquier
forma Mostrar Esperanza alegría y
bienestar en la ropa
es eso es lo que me llega también es muy
evocador
uno no se dice que pertenece
necesariamente a un espacio definido
geográficamente
bocamundos universos paisajes es
poéticos
pero tienes algunos defectos no que yo
sepa no que yo sepa
[Risas]
[Música]
la familia el grupo cuando la relación
funciona se vuelve entonces una fuente
inagotable en abundancia y
enriquecimiento personal